j'ai envie d'aller m'installer sur la
planète mars et d'y vivre pour le
restant de mes jours
parce que quand j'étais petite fille je
voulais visiter tous les mondes de
l'univers
parce que la terre est le berceau de
l'humanité mais qu'on ne passe pas toute
sa vie dans un berceau parce qu'aucun
être humain n'est encore jamais vu une
autre planète de ses propres yeux parce
que je suis pas très optimiste quant à
la survie à court moyen et long terme de
l'humanité et que je voudrais savoir si
nous pouvons survivre dans un
environnement extrêmement hostile parce
que parce que la planète mars peut
permettre de répondre à certaines
questions comme pourquoi la vie est
apparue sur terre et que je voudrais
beaucoup participer à ce genre de
recherche scientifique parce que ça me
passionne parce que ça me fascine parce
que j'en ai envie mais ouais après tout
mais quelle meilleure réponse que l'
envie pour justifier un choix mais
pourquoi vous êtes venus ici vous ce
soir parce que vous en aviez envie non
j'espère je sais pas mais quand on a un
choix à faire en général on prend
l'option qui nous plaît le plus
personne au restaurant ne se dit j'ai
bien envie de l'entrecôte alors mettez
moi la salade ce sera parfait non
personne jamais alors vous allez prendre
l'entrecôte parce que vous en avez envie
mais il y aura toujours quelqu'un pour
vous dire oui mais attention tu as déjà
mangé de la viande rouge hier tu sais ça
ne se fait pas ça ne se fait pas
quand j'étais ado comme beaucoup d'ados
j'écrivais des chansons et des poèmes
j'aimais particulièrement les sonnets et
les alexandrins et pour les chansons
j'ai essayé d'utiliser un vocabulaire et
les tournures de phrases un peu élaboré
quelques années plus tard je cherche un
job pour financer mes études je réponds
à l'annonce d'un vieux monsieur qui
cherchent une aide administrative je me
présente chez lui et au cours de la
conversation j'apprends qu'il est
président d'une association de poètes
je lui dis que moi aussi j'ai écrit des
poèmes il me demande quel genre de
poèmes
je lui réponds que j'aime
particulièrement les sonnets et les
alexandrins et là il a un petit air très
méprisant très blessants et il me dit
mais ça ne se fait plus ma petite
on n'écrit plus de sonner d'alexandrins
depuis très longtemps je ne décroche pas
le job et j'arrête d'écrire des poèmes
peu de temps après je me présente au
concours d'entrée de l'école d'auteurs
compositeurs d'alice dona je m'installe
au piano et j'interprète de mon mieux
évidemment la chanson que j'ai composée
et que j'ai écrite de manière un peu
élaborée je joue le dernier accord est
là un silence un peu trop long à mon
goût s'installe alice dona fini par
prendre la parole me pose cette simple
question est ce que vous vous sentez
bien dans votre époque
et oui voilà je suis complètement
déstabilisé du coup elle s'explique non
mais parce qu'en fait on dirait que vous
parlez comme dans les liaisons
dangereuses
ça ne se fait plus on n'écrit plus de
paroles de chansons comme ça je suis
recalés et j'arrête d'écrire des
chansons
quelques années plus tard patrick poivre
d'arvor organise un concours littéraire
pour fêter les 20 ans de son émission
vol de nuit il faut écrire un texte sur
un personnage de la littérature qui nous
a marqués je me souviens du vieux
monsieur poète
je me souviens d'alice dona j'essaye
donc d'écrire un texte sur un personnage
qui m'a plu mais bon enfin voilà sans
non plus en fait et je n'y arrive pas je
n'y arrive pas c'est tout ce que je fais
c'est mauvais je jette je sais pas vains
brouillon ça me saoule je fini par
abandonner quelques semaines se passe
et puis le jour de la fermeture du
concours je ressens le besoin d'écrire
ce que j'avais dans les tripes
depuis le début j'ouvre un document word
trente minutes plus tard mon texte était
prêt je le relis à peine et je l'envoie
j'ai gagné le concours je l' ai gagnée
avec un texte sur le vicomte de valmont
des liaisons dangereuses que j'ai écrit
entièrement on alexandre
c'est cher alexandra qui me tiennent à
coeur que je me lire entendre et écrire
à toute heure ouais c'est comme de la
musique j'adore le rythme que ça dégage
ça ne pas où ça me touche et au fond
mais qui m'empêche d'écrire des
alexandrins
le vieux monsieur poète et alice dona
sondés personne tout à fait respectable
et reconnus par leurs pairs
mais moi je suis parfaitement libres
d'écrire ce que j'ai envie d'écrire
cette histoire m'a enseigné deux choses
la première c'est que décidé de rester
fidèle à soi-même c'est prendre le
risque de ne pas être en adéquation avec
ce qui se fait la deuxième c'est que ce
risque est toujours payant parce que
même si j'avais perdu concours de toute
façon j'avais besoin d'écrire ce texte
comme je le ressentais parce qu'il me
ressemblait parce qu'ils étaient moins
parce qu'ils étaient ceux qui se
faisaient pour moi et parce que j'ai
fini par comprendre qu'au fond personne
ne peut empêcher de faire ce que j'avais
envie de faire
alors faire ce qui ne se fait pas quand
on participe à un concours littéraire
c'est une chose quand il s'agit de choix
plus important d'un c'en est une autre
aller à contre courant de ce qui se fait
demande beaucoup plus de travail
beaucoup plus d'énergie que d'emprunter
des voies qui sont déjà tout tracé
enfin c'est vrai tous ici au moins une
fois dans notre vie on a abandonné un
rêve un projet cette jolie veste jaune
canari ou ou un texto pour proposer un
verre à une personne parce qu'on avait
peur parce qu'on pensait que c'était
impossible que ça ne se faisait pas mais
au fond qui nous empêche de faire ce
qu'on avait envie de faire le plus
souvent le plus souvent la réponse à
cette question c'est nous mêmes alors
oui quand il s'agit de projets quand il
s'agit de choix quand il s'agit d'
ambition très personnelle ça peut faire
peur
ouais ça peut être compliqué aussi les
autres peuvent penser que ce n'est pas
sérieux et donc qu'on est fous ou que ça
ne se fait pas mais alors réussir à
faire ce qu'on a envie de faire
n'est pas toujours impossible mais loin
de là moi dans mon entourage et des gens
qui me le prouve tous les jours
cette copine à moi par exemple qui a
toujours rêvé d'être musicienne qui est
monteuse pour la télévision mais qui
part dans trois jours la s'installer en
norvège avec son mec pour ouvrir une
école de musique et qui sort son premier
album à la rentrée de septembre
cet autre ami qui a finalement fait le
choix de divorcer parce qu'il s'est
rendu compte que ses enfants avaient
plus besoin d'un papa séparé qu'il soit
bien dans ses baskets plutôt que d'un
papa toujours mariés mais qui n'arrivait
plus à être lui-même dans cette relation
ou cette autre ami qui propose un texte
à un grand éditeur qui lui demande s'il
n'a pas autre chose qui répond si si
bien sûr alors qu'il n'a rien et qui
deux ans plus tard et traduit dans neuf
langues et moi ben moi qui voulais
visiter tous les mondes de l'univers
quand j'étais petite fille et qui suit
maintenant candidate pour un aller
simple vers mars
alors c'est pas commun je vous la corde
du coup je fais face à un peu tous les
types de détracteurs il ya ceux qui
savent c'est impossible ça se fera
jamais peut-être mais personne n'en sait
rien et puis on disait déjà ça pour la
lune et il ya toujours des gens pour
dire qu'on l'a jamais fait il ya ceux
qui ricanent qui me prennent pour une
débile mais tu ne t'es au courant qui a
pas de billet retour ou oui oui oui je
suis au courant oui à mai alors donc ça
ne te fait pas peur si si ça me fait
peur mais la peur est un moyen pas un
frein et puis il ya ceux qui s'énervent
ça c'est mes préférés mais tu as
complètement folle c'est du suicide
on jamais tu vas mourir oui oui je vais
mourir mais vous aussi
c'est fou c'est impossible ça fait peur
où j'ai été la première en fait à me
dire tout ça et j'ai bien failli ne pas
m'inscrire pour toutes ces raisons mais
j'ai fini par le faire parce que j'en
avais envie
et parce que j'ai fini par comprendre
que j'étais la seule qui m'empêchait de
le faire alors je me suis inscrite comme
200 2585 autres candidats à travers le
monde
un projet qui s'appelle marc swan qui
envisage sérieusement d'établir une base
humaine permanente sur la planète mars
aujourd'hui il ne reste que 7 105
candidats toujours en lice et j'en fais
partie et c'était pas gagné
enfin je veux dire enfin voila quand je
suis né aucune bonne femme s'est penché
sur mon berceau et m'a dit alors toi
plus tard tu seras comédienne auteure
chroniqueuse tu te sentiras vachement
bien dans son époque
donc tu gagneras un concours littéraire
en 2008 avec des alexandrins et
peut-être que tu mourras travailler sur
mars
non personne n'a dit ça jamais non non
moi je fais comme tout le monde
enfin je vois là quand je suis né mais
mes proches autour de moi ont commencé à
tirer des plans sur la comète
quand elle sera grande ben voila j'ai 30
ans je mesure 1 mètre 57
voilà pourquoi il ne faut jamais tirer
de plans sur la comète
donc moi j'ai choisi de viser mars mars
mars et ben c'est un environnement
extrêmement hostile mars
c'est une planète qui se trouve à
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
kilomètres il fait moins 63 degrés en
moyenne
l'atmosphère est composé à 95% de co2 il
n'y a pas d'eau liquide
on ya trouvé aucune trace de vie y est
elle est bombardée en permanence par des
rayons cosmiques
est ce que je fais une erreur
est ce que c'est un mauvais choix mais
au fond finalement est-ce que j'en ai
vraiment envie à chaque grandes
décisions que nous avons à prendre dans
notre vie ces questions se posent
et c'est souvent très difficile d'y voir
clair mais j'ai vécu une autre
expérience qui m'a beaucoup appris j'ai
toujours voulu être comédienne mais mes
parents m'ont toujours vu journalistes
ils ont donc accepté de financer mon
école de comédie musicale à condition
que je reprenne de vraies études pour
avoir un vrai diplôme
une fois formés en chant en danse et en
théâtre je suis donc retourné à la fac
et pour la cinquième année j'ai décidé
de faire un master de journalisme
c'était un master en alternance c'était
un master professionnel donc c'était en
alternance et il fallait que je trouve
un contrat d'apprentissage
après cinq mois de recherches intensives
je ne trouvais toujours rien et puis un
soir de novembre
il s'est passé exactement la même chose
que le jour de la fermeture du concours
de vol de nuit de manière totalement
irréfléchi et incontrôlée j'ai ouvert un
document word et 30 minutes plus tard
j'avais écrit et mis en forme mon cv
court métrage façon amélie poulain sept
jours après il était en ligne
trois mois plus tard et avait fait le
tour du web et des médias de france et
d'ailleurs et cinq ans après il est
toujours cité en exemple
mais je ne suis pas en train de vous
exposer crânement en exploits
extraordinaires loin de là parce qu'en
fait c'était un échec
je n'ai jamais trouvé mon contrat
d'apprentissage pourquoi cette question
m'a obsédé pendant des années mais mais
des années et puis il ya pas si
longtemps gelé re visionner alors on me
voit m'amuser la jouer mon propre rôle
avec beaucoup d'autodérision des
caricatures ont mis entend faire la voix
falla manière d'andré dussollier on y
voit des extraits de spectacles auxquels
j'ai participé mais jamais à aucun
moment je ne parle de journalisme
je n'ai donc jamais trouvé mon contrat
d'apprentissage mais deux ans plus tard
ce cv vidéo m'a permis de décrocher un
job en or à la télévision où j'ai fait
des tas de choses dont jouer la comédie
écrire trois pages d'alexandrins c'est
beaucoup de travail et d'énergie
reprendre des études de journalisme
c'est beaucoup de travail et d'énergie
réalisé un court métrage c'est beaucoup
de travail et d'énergie et faire partie
des 750 candidats restants pour un aller
simple vers mars c'est beaucoup de
travail et d'énergie
alors pourquoi certaines choses
fonctionnent et d'autres pas
je ne suis pas journaliste je l' ai
toujours su je ne pouvais pas devenir
journaliste parce que je ne pouvais pas
devenir ce que je ne suis pas en
revanche
enfin je ne sais pas vous mais moi je me
sens bien là sur scène à vous raconter
des histoires et et c'est la même chose
devant un micro ou devant une caméra et
en fait je me rends compte que je suis
sur un tapis rond et rouge
on dirait que lui sur mars sur scène
voilà c'est comme si c'était là ma place
dans l'univers
et voilà bah c'est génial on peut pas
lutter contre soi même on ne peut pas se
mentir
en tout cas ma pas longtemps ni son
dommage
nous devons donc faire les choix qui
sont les nôtres
même si ça ne se fait pas et vous savez
ce qui est encore plus jouissif pour moi
que de faire ce qui ne se fait pas bah
c'est de faire ce qui ne s'est encore
jamais fait
j'ai l'univers dans mon adn je suis
comédienne parce que j'aime tellement la
vie que je veux en vivre plusieurs à la
fois je suis auteur et je suis
chroniqueuse parce que j'aime raconter
des histoires et je sais pas je ne sais
pas si je raconterai la suite de celle
ci depuis mars
mais si je vais jusqu'au bout de
l'aventuré alors mars me permettra de
visiter un des autres démons de
l'univers mars me permettra de vivre une
deuxième vie mars me permettra de
raconter une histoire des histoires
inédites dans toute l'histoire de toutes
les civilisations et surtout ben surtout
je compte bien raconter les premières
impressions des premiers pas sur le sol
martien
même si ce sont pas les miens sous la
forme d'un sonnet en alexandrins
ça ne se fait pas oui je sais mais j'en
ai envie alors je le ferai